so transcendence is directed by
Christopher Nolan's preferred
cinematographer it stars Johnny Depp
Rebecca Hall Paul Bettany a whole bunch
of other people on loan from Christopher
Nolan it's about AI this movie has so
much potential transcendence is directed
by wally pfister and stars Johnny Depp
Rebecca Hall Morgan Freeman Killian
Murphy Paul Bettany humongously talented
cast in this movie and basically what
this film is about is a very very smart
scientist and his wife who discover a
way to enhance AI they're looking for
ways to create new intelligences through
computers they're really trying hard to
make a breakthrough and they are just on
the very cusp of creating a computer
consciousness and he gets shot by
someone who is involved with this group
that's very much against all of these
ideas but at the last second they decide
you know what we're going to try this on
him we're gonna upload him into a
computer and see if he becomes a
consciousness see if he becomes
self-aware and see what happens when
that eventually does happen things start
to go in a very bad path as he starts to
try to control way too many things now
as I said in my intro transcendence had
a lot of potential great cast a
first-time director however one of the
better cinematographers working today
and a very very interesting premise I
didn't hear anything about the response
to this film going in I had no idea what
kind of film I was going to experience
so I was very disappointed when I
experienced a pretty terrible movie
transcendence is just bad it's extremely
unfortunate for me to be telling you
this this is a movie that has characters
as flat and as lifeless as a machine
which is very interesting considering
the plot of this movie but seriously the
characters in this film are so
two-dimensional there is not a single
interesting thing that happens the only
interesting thing is the actual setup
once the idea is set up and you're like
that sounds cool what are they gonna do
with this he does nothing he gives his
wife a lot of money he tries to figure
out ways to cure various things and kind
of create his own little Empire but none
of it is interesting and none of it is
really told with any emotion you never
once feel like there's any tension in
the film every single person I talked to
after this
raining all said the same thing I was
bored out of my mind
and I gotta be honest I was bored out of
my mind I wanted to go to sleep
I watched the movie from beginning to
end but this two-hour film felt like 2
hours and 45 minutes how's Johnny Depp
in the movie great actor loved the guy
has he really done anything of Merit
lately not so much I've been wanting him
to play a more normal character and for
a large portion of this movie he does
until he's uploaded into a computer of
course but his character was so
uninteresting even before he became an
AI once he's an AI he's even less
interesting because he doesn't do
anything he just sits there and goes
hello I'm in a computer Oh would you
like some money I'll fill up your bank
account with lots of money dear it's
just this endless string of like really
this is where you're gonna take this
incredible idea I mean they could have
made essentially a prequel to terminator
they could have had like the first big
artificial intelligence that creates
Skynet that blows up the world and all
he does is fill out people's bank
accounts and learn how to cure some
diseases and kind of starts to create
his own army of people who are super
strong but nothing thrilling happens
there's like one action scene in this
movie and it seems as if it was like the
studio was like hey you should probably
put something in here and so they like
re shot it and put an action scene
seriously it's like 40 seconds long and
then there's like this big overblown
finale but none of it seems to matter
because he focuses so much on these two
characters and the relationship between
Johnny Depp and Rebecca Hall as she's
trying to find a way to maintain her
husband's life but it's so bland that
you don't care about it and since so
much attention is given it the movie
itself becomes so bland Morgan Freeman
and Killian Murphy are two of my
favorite actors they have got nothing to
do in this movie it's almost like they
were like hey you've worked with us a
lot of Nolan's movies we're gonna be in
this movie for you they've got nothing
to do at all they are two people like I
don't even know what their character is
what their purpose is they got a couple
random scenes and there's
they don't add a single thing to the
movie they're just there see wally
pfister can create a beautiful image
he's obviously a very good
cinematographer but there's a lot that
goes into directing that I don't really
think he's tapped into for one tone and
pacing and creating characters on screen
that you actually care about that's not
present in this movie at all the
screenplay has something to do with it
as well now a little bit of insight I do
have into the screenplay is that a good
friend of mine who was originally from
Ohio who has actually gotten some fame
for writing some pretty cool screenplays
who moved to LA he went to the screening
with me today and he said he actually
read the first draft of that script and
said it was fantastic he said he has no
idea what happened to that script he
said it was completely butchered no I'm
just that's hearsay for my friend I
can't say cuz I didn't read the first
draft but he said the first draft was
fantastic and he has no idea what
happened this movie said it was
originally a very very thrilling action
adventure film with a good dramatic heft
to it this film in my opinion is an
incredibly hokey drama with boring
characters very very bland storytelling
and nothing of interest that actually
takes place the best part of this movie
is by far Paul Bettany he has the best
character in the film he goes through
the most changes and you feel for him he
gave a very good performance Johnny Depp
in the film didn't have anything to do
Rebecca Hall was trying very hard to
give a good performance but the majority
of the actors in this film just feel as
if they're weighted down by this bloated
and uninteresting story that is a
humongous disappointment I was bored
throughout the entire movie biggest
thing I take away from this movie is
just how much input no one actually
gives to his films that wally pfister
lenses for him because for goodness
sakes there isn't even a shred of that
emotion in this movie I'm gonna give
transcendence a d-plus it has an
intriguing plot Paul Bettany was very
good in the film but it goes nowhere
nothing of interest happens with this
intriguing plot nothing that could have
been awesome is even touched when you
guys do see the movie if you do I don't
recommend seeing it this is actually a
very disappointing movie in one of the
most disappointing films I've seen in
months but if you do see the flow I'm
interested in knowing where you thought
of it and as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man eyes